an effort to build a baseball stadium in
Las Vegas has a lot of hurdles to get
over before it becomes a reality right
now the plan would be to put it where
the Tropicana Hotel Casino sits we take
a look at what would need to happen
before that can become reality
the first hurdle was last night's
hearing on 380 million in public
financing for the stadium project the
legislative session ends next Monday at
midnight and before then it will have to
get approved by two committees the state
senate and the State Assembly otherwise
it would have to happen in a special
session now the deal currently has the
support of the culinary and construction
unions as well as Clark County Tina
Quigley from the Las Vegas global
economic Alliance says taxpayers will
get the money back eventually it is
money that is gifted up front but it is
cut does come back and even if they were
to pack up and go away they have got
stop gaps in the legislation that would
protect the public so I do feel like the
our legislators our County leaders have
done a good job at making sure that the
public is protected Democratic
assemblyman Howard Watts asked if this
is the right project for a valuable Las
Vegas strip location any other
development idea for this site if this
were not in play would likely probably
bring in as much or more than the
Tropicana does in its current state it's
kind of the the A's of the strip the
bill only needs a simple majority to
pass now at a 30 000 seat capacity it
would be the smallest Major League
ballpark the economic projections are
based on a near sellout of 28 000 fans
for all 81 home games in 2022 the
Oakland A's had an average attendance of
only about 10 000 fans to date out of
the nearly 2400 online opinions
submitted on the bill 78 percent oppose
it
there are a lot of questions that need
to be answered such as how the traffic
on that busy Corner would be handled if
the bill passes the other baseball team
owners would need to waive the
relocation fees for the ace